All right.
And now
to a CNN exclusive, chilling new details
about the attack on the husband of House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi.
A source familiar with the incident
tells CNN that the suspected assailant
had a bag of zip ties during the break in
on Friday.
Paul Pelosi is still recovering
in a hospital this morning.
He suffered a skull fracture
and injuries to his hands and right arm
when he was struck with a hammer.
President Biden
speaking about the attack
for the first time and blasting
those who have propped up
conspiracy theories
It's one thing to condemn the violence,
but you can't condemn the violence
unless you condemn those people.
Continue to argue
the election was not real
that is being stolen.
That all the
all the Milwaukee that's been
put out there to undermine democracy
CNN Sunlen Serfaty
has more from Washington.
Sunlen, we're
also hearing from the House
speaker for the first time
since this attack.
What does she have to say?
That's right, Fred.
And you can really hear the raw emotion
in her voice
when she put out this statement
using words
like heartbreaking and traumatizing
to describe this attack.
That happened on her husband.
And she says in court in part, quote,
Friday morning,
a violent man broke into our family home,
demanded to confront me
and brutally attacked my husband, Paul.
Our children,
our grandchildren and I
are heartbroken
and traumatized by the life
threatening attack on our pop.
We are grateful for the quick
response of law enforcement
and emergency services
and for the lifesaving medical care
he is receiving.
And one part of good news
in this statement,
she does mention that her husband
is continuing to have a better condition,
he says.
She says every day
his condition gets better.
This was her first statement
coming from her own voice
since the attack on Friday.
And this was a dear colleague
that was sent to members
and staff on Capitol Hill.
And it comes also at a time
that there is
heightened anxiety about members
and their family members,
personal safety
and a lot of lawmakers are frustrated.
They also received a letter yesterday
from the House sergeant of arms
and the chief of the US
Capitol Police updating them
about what existing protocol is in place
to protect them,
what services are already offered.
But again,
a lot of members,
especially in light of this latest
brutal attack,
say that's not good enough
and are frustrated
and want more security.
So that's something that certainly
this week, Fred, will be on top of mind.
And many lawmakers mind as they
grapple with the
fallout from this brutal attack.
Sunlen Serfaty in Washington,
thank you so much.
Meantime, House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy
is weighing in on the attack
and he did so again in the last
hour saying this on Fox News.
Let me be perfectly clear violence
or threat of violence
has no place in our society.
And what happened to Paul
Pelosi is wrong.
Having heard it,
I reached out and called the speaker
she was on a plane back for her husband,
but so we were able to communicate
by text.
She did say that the surgery went well.
I wanted to convey
that our thoughts and prayers
were with her and her family
and with Paul.
And we hope for him a speedy recovery
and that we're able to stop this crime
across our country.
Of course, this gets
really deranged and others
joining us right now,
Illinois Democrat Congressman
Raja Krishnamoorthi, a congressman.
So good to see you.
So, you know,
I wonder you know,
while the minority leader
is condemning violence, he didn't
address the spread of conspiracy theories
that may have led up to an attack
like what was experienced on Paul Pelosi.
I mean, he said
violence has no place in our society.
What happened to Paul Pelosi is wrong.
I mean, without being disrespectful,
I mean, that's
just overstating the obvious.
But does it more need to be said
from leadership of all parties?
I mean, what is the risk of,
say, the minority leader?
Not saying more than that.
You're correct, Fredricka.
And first of all,
I think everybody is praying for Paul
Pelosi speedy recovery
at this point, as well
as for the speaker and her family.
But I think what Mr.
McCarthy didn't say was that
this is a form
of political violence, Fredricka.
What the assailant shouted upon entry
into the Pelosi household was,
where's Nancy? Where's Nancy?
And that echoed exactly the chants
of the January six insurrectionists
when they breached the Capitol
And this is just the culmination
of the demonization of Nancy Pelosi
by many folks
on the other side of the aisle.
You know, my colleague
Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Facebook post called for
her being found to have committed treason
and saying
that execution was appropriate.
A GOP candidate for Senate
in the Arizona primary
last year
ran a Super Bowl
ad featuring him
shooting Nancy Pelosi in the ad.
So this type of dangerous,
violent rhetoric
is going to lead to the natural result,
which is violence.
And that's what happened with populism.
So is it your belief
that if it were a Marjorie Taylor Greene
or perhaps even Minority Leader
McCarthy, if they were to say
more forcefully
singling out
people
who are coming from a
particular persuasion
ought not to be violent,
not to help incite violence,
to stop saying aloud
the dangerous things
that you just reiterate
How much of a difference might that make
in your view
that make a big difference?
Denouncing political violence
of all stripes
would make a big difference
whether it's by elected officials
or by former presidents like Donald Trump
or by candidates for office.
And let me just say one other thing.
I think that we have to look at the role
of social media
in amplifying
this dangerous, violent rhetoric.
You know, Facebook and Twitter
and other platforms
make a lot of money
from this type of rhetoric.
And the polarization
that results from it.
And we have to look very closely
at repealing that liability
that they enjoy
from the negative consequences
associated with with this type of content
that is routinely trafficked on
their platforms as well.